en Ukraine Kiev vivent personne ou
encore crier dans le Sud ont été de
nouveau visées par des attaques
aériennes russes des explosions ont été
entendues dans la nuit l'armée
ukrainienne affirme que toutes les
cibles se déplaçant en direction de la
capitale ont été détruites l'armée russe
multiplie ses attaques depuis plusieurs
semaines et la contre-offensive
ukrainienne se fait attendre mais les
conditions météorologiques ne sont pas
idéales l'armée ukrainiennes attend
toujours des armes indispensables pour
mener cette contrefontive regardez le
reportage de Maryse Burgaud Stéphane
Guillemot et Bruno Bervas
un blindé de transport de troupes
fournis par les Américains une image
rare ces véhicules sont si précieux que
les Ukrainiens refusent le plus souvent
de les montrer
nous sommes près d'une ligne de front
dans un lieu que nous devons garder
secrets à l'intérieur ces soldats
racontent qu'ils n'ont pas assez de
véhicules blindés de ce type et c'est en
partie pour cela que la grande offensive
ne commence pas avec les voitures comme
ça on pourra protéger plus les
spectacles Ukrainiens plus on a des
machines plus c'est des vis sauvées
la France vient d'ailleurs de promettre
de livrer plus d'engins de cette
catégorie avec les voitures simples on
peut pas faire ça il peut nous tuer avec
ça c'est presque impossible d'être tué
le blindé est soigneusement caché il ne
doit pas être repéré par les drones de
l'ennemi russe plus loin d'autres
véhicules blindés des 4x4 fournis par
les États-Unis
ce citoyen américain combat dans les
rangs Ukrainiens se blindage lui a déjà
sauvé la vie à deux reprises
j'ai survécu à une mine posée par les
Russes et un missile antichar grâce à ça
un autre front ces soldats se mettent en
position ils vont viser l'ennemi avec ce
mortier moderne
c'est une arme fournie par la Finlande
mais leurs obus en revanche sont de
l'époque soviétique ils ont donc un bon
mortier mais des obus inadaptés ce
manque de projectile explique aussi
pourquoi l'offensive se fait attendre
on se dépêche on a plus que 5 minutes
la grande offensive leur but aujourd'hui
est de détruire une mitrailleuse ennemie
mission réussie nous distille quand nous
nous arrêtons plus loin dans une zone
moins exposée
selon ses soldats le terrain encore trop
humide retarde de la taque annonce
l'équipement est souvent très lourd les
chars par exemple et la boue pourrait
poser problème et nous empêcher
d'avancer
ces militaires attendent donc le grand
jour tout en menant des offensives de
préparation la plupart des équipements
les plus sensibles c'est-à-dire par
exemple les chars lourds les Léopards
les challengers fournis par les
Européens sont cachés à l'arrière du
front et la plupart de ces charmes
sortiront que pour la grande offensive